well let's say to Scotland where we can
talk to the SMPS Foreign Affairs and
Europe spokesman Steven getting's it's
good to see you this morning and it's
good to have you on because what we
don't get to do often south of the
border if you like is properly look at
the the domestic agenda in Scotland and
what you are actually offering Scottish
voters so can we work through through
some of that and kick off with education
because we know Nicola Sturgeon said
when she became at First Minister that
education was her top priority why is it
that the education in education system
in Scotland seems to be underperforming
compared to where it was a few years ago
well look one thing that the Scottish
government does and it's focused on its
domestic agenda and focused on
delivering and I'm somebody who sits at
Westminster where every time I you key
government tries to fulfill the
legislative agenda falls flat on its
face and we end up in snap elections and
chaos and one of the things that they've
tried to do is as John Swinney in
particular doing a good job of trying to
look at the whole different areas so
that you know look at poverty look at
these areas that might impact on pupil
performance and that's clearly there the
right thing to do and I have to see it
stands in stark contrast to the chaos
that I witness on a day-to-day basis
during my time in Parliament at
Westminster over the past four and a
half years I mean documents released in
September said that higher exams in
Scotland at the lowest level in a decade
exam rates have fallen every year except
at the National five level year-on-year
pass rates are down anywhere between one
point one and three point six percent I
mean well whatever is happening in the
rest of the country that's ultimately
the SMPS responsibility isn't it well
yet and if you look at those figures
you'll see that more students are more
pupils are going on to positive
destinations and part of that was when
the SNP came into power you scrapped
tuition fees you know I've the
university sector is really important
where I am and
that's incredibly important for sending
more students on to positive
destinations regardless of their
backgrounds based on the ability to
learn not the ability to pee but there
are more substantial issues that we need
to deal with it there's Westminster
election and it is a Westminster
election a decade of austerity first
under the Tory liberal administration
and then under the Tories has an impact
on public services you cannot have
continual salami slicing and not expect
it to have an impact and then the
Scottish government has tried to offset
that by raising taxes very slightly for
those who are better off with the vast
majority and being slightly better off
or no worse off and that's the right
thing to do in they're focused on that
and you have to remember the Scottish
government fulfills its legislative
agenda the UK government is nowhere near
getting involved in this with issues
like domestic violence bills being
dropped because of the chaos and
confusion at Westminster the Scottish
Parliament the Scottish Government is
getting on with the job on a day to day
basis I mean is it really we talk about
domestic violence and issues of that
nature what about the the drug problem
but the worst drug addiction problem in
Europe and the budget was cut by 50
million pounds well you're absolutely
right to raise that and that's a good
point that's a human tragedy and let's
not forget the human tragedy and the
hearts of the drug tracers throughout
the United Kingdom and one of the areas
that the Scottish government has looked
at has been looking at safe rooms that's
something that's practiced elsewhere in
Europe and in Canada as well and that's
managed to bring down drugs deaths and
that's something that was backed and
devolution of those powers was backed by
the cross-party
Scottish Affairs Select Committee so
when you have a problem you identify
what could possibly be a solution that's
the stuff of governance a stuff of
sensible governance and for the UK
government to refuse to devolve those
powers even though it's something that
could be tried could make that better
makes you wonder about the that dog much
trying centralized by the UK government
there's a solution that could try and
tackle that human tragedy the Scottish
government have called for it
the cross-party Scottish Affairs Select
Committee at Westminster have called for
it and yet Westminster and the Tory
stand in the way of trying to make some
pro
yes why is everything that goes wrong
being harmed offer being at the fault of
Westminster when when obviously there
are there there are issues that the SMP
can address directly within the Scottish
Parliament
drug-related deaths almost doubling in
eight years to become the highest in
here now whatever the the processes the
policies and the protocols from
Westminster you can take the other
action on that can't you
oh wait a minute I'm sorry and I have to
here we've got a situation and the drugs
one's a really good one to raise that
any government regardless of color and I
think that our right to thinking people
across the political spectrum we're
trying to think how do we deal with this
tragedy now you have the Scottish
Affairs Select Committee cross party
labour members conservative members SNP
members working across party bases it's
one of the fury as I think works very
effectively at Westminster the Select
Committee system have identified this as
a possible solution no we have a
Westminster election campaign that's
what people would be voting on in a week
and a half the Scottish government have
said this could be a possible solution
there is no one-size-fits-all but that
could be a possible solution to this
particular crisis and so the SNP you put
that in their manifesto I'm standing on
that manifesto and that's something the
SNP MPs will fight for if I've ever
liked it in a week and a half and
incidentally the Scottish Government
looking at this issue have identified
this as a possible solution it's a bit
like minimum pricing for alcohol which
was rejected for so long by Westminster
worked up in Scotland and then was
copied elsewhere in the United Kingdom
look if there's a potential solution
that let's look at it and I'm not saying
that this will be the magic bullet but
let's give it a try there's a human
tragedy and to everything from death so
they are give a short I'm sorry to say
we've got to leave it there it's been
very good to talk to you this morning
thank you